Now in looking at what
actually keeps airplanes up,
we can just look at
the shape of the wing,
which is a cross-section
of an aircraft wing,
and think of the air passing
over the wing rather than
the wing passing
through the air.
The results will be the same.
And, in fact, in wind
tunnels, of course,
the wing is held stationary,
the air is blown past it.
So if you get that
picture to begin with,
you'll see that the air
has to divide some of it
over the top and some
of it underneath.
And the air that
goes through the top
produces certain
effects in combination
with the air that
goes underneath that
does, in fact, affect
the lift and produces
the upward force of the wing.
Now to explain that we have
first a little experiment
that we will show you
called Venturi tube.
And if I come around
and turn the machine on,
you can see what happens.
This is water flow not air.
But the arrangement and the
results will be similar.
Now we have a tube here, which
is shaped in a particular way.
It's not the same
section everywhere.
There's a narrow
throat at that point.
And there is a wide
section at the inlet
and a wide section at the outlet.
In fact, the water is
now flowing through it.
The valve, I think, is open.
And you can see
from these tubes--
which are attached to holes
at the top of the main stream tube
that the pressure, in fact, is
different in different sections
of the tube.
Where the tube is
narrow the water
must be going faster
because the water is
virtually incompressible.
So here is fast flowing
water at the neck
and slow flowing water at
the two ends of the tube.
And the difference
in the pressure
is shown by the
level of liquids,
which you can see in the tubes.
Here, the pressure is low.
It's not holding up much
liquid.
And here the pressure is higher.
So we would conclude
from that the
faster that the liquid goes
then the less the pressure.
And in fact, it
is that basic idea
that keeps the airplane
up as we looked
at the wing a few minutes ago.
The mathematical
form of the result
is shown on the
slide there, which
relates the velocity
of the flow, which
is u, to the pressure.
In the relationship
of that kind,
it's called Bernoulli's law.
And it says that if
the pressure goes up...
Let me say that again.
If the velocity goes up, then
the pressure will go down
and conversely.
So where the water or
the air is flowing faster
that will be the lower pressure.
And in fact, that effect
is what keeps the wing up.
When the air divides
over the wing,
it has to travel rather
faster on the top section
than it does underneath.
And the difference
between the two pressures
provides the lift.